do you not think that sounds very kind
of shallow in terms of the way you look
at things like i i think it depends on
what what you need as a person because
your circumstances your upbringing your
life is gonna determine what you need
from someone else you're right there
there's individual differences but when
you survey women and ask them like from
the horse's mouth at large what they
want in them and a guy it's money
muscles frame game
what do you mean by frame sorry frame is
like masculinity basically muscles and i
will say when you said it's also what
you need personally from a woman i was
going to point out today i've you know
we've all been there where like you meet
someone at a time where they need a
certain kind of guy maybe she's been
dumped by some you know some player and
she needs a nice guy for a bit but after
those needs have been met
it's money frames and games baby i
wasn't going to no to that point i was
going to say why is it about what you
need like i don't think a man goes into
a relationship saying
what can what do i need from a woman
it's like no like what can i provide for
her what can our family do together what
where could like um i promise you i'm
not like what if a man says he wants
something from you you would think he's
a weirdo he'd be like right he's like
well it's it's it's like why does he
want something from me like no you tell
your bridge and if you if you if say for
example
you got a friend where the guy's she's
constantly paying for or she's
constantly doing um the things that you
would typically consider a man doing
yeah you would tell her you'd be like
later why are you with that guy like
he's trying to take advantage of you
yeah
you see there we go i've heard i've
heard that i've heard that being said
right so that's what i'm talking about
when i say in terms of what you need
from that i think with i don't know if
it's with age
but money
genuinely doesn't come into it for me
don't get me wrong don't get me wrong
i'm not gonna lie i i will not i will
sit here and i'll be honest
if i met you guys
if i met two guys exact same guy and one
said yeah exact same guy and one said
do you want to go out on monday
i'm gonna pick you up
and the other one said do you wanna go
out on monday
yeah we'll check train times and i'll
meet you there yeah
i'm not gonna lie
i probably will go for the one that's
gonna pick me up right yeah what if i
told you the train guy has 35 million in
his bank account and the reason why wait
wait wait and the reason why he's not
taking car and pick dropping news
because it's in the garage would you
still go with the guy that's picking you
up in the car
yeah no i don't know that i'm confused
now you're confused
you can you confuse everyone you don't
know what you want
a man just needs to be able to look
after himself yeah i just feel like
you've kind of got your stuff together
but the point is if there's a guy a and
guy b and one has money and one what
does it yeah you're telling me you
wouldn't pick the guy with money it's
exactly exactly the same yeah yeah you
probably would yeah
i mean if there's not really a good
comparison if they're exactly the same
but just one has money of course you're
going to pick the one with the money
because then you're not going to put
your your your stuff but the point is
that plays into it where men don't care
men don't care all about a woman's money
like and a lot of times girls will come
out and they'll say oh i have my own bag
and like think that's attractive to a
guy but it's only attractive to broke
man yeah of course
if you have the exact same comparison
though and you say to a guy okay has
women a and women b who are exactly the
same and the only thing how would you
pick between the two then yeah
it would be money
that comes down to what would it be but
for us you're as human
can you answer this question
okay so
just rephrase the question so girl a
girl b one has money one doesn't one
makes 500k a year one makes forty five
but they're exactly the same and that's
exactly the same yeah
money won't i i don't care about money
and the reason why i won't care about
money is purely because i'm gonna judge
them like let's say girl a they're
exactly the same but
girl is like hella disrespectful she
doesn't understand what i as a man need
and then gilby exactly the same
understands what a man needs
is submissive in certain ways that shows
me respect and loyalty which is what i
value
i'm picking gilbee
so so so then
being exactly the same it does money
doesn't matter can i actually
flip a
said as a minute ago you said they don't
understand what i need now when i said
looking at what you'd look at what you
need from a man you picked up on that
and said why does it matter what the
woman needs and assumed it was a
monetary value thing where i was talking
about emotionally and mentally but when
you've said that
nobody said anything that's not what i'm
talking about he's talking about in
terms of the man's needs in terms of a
man's needs i could fulfill my own needs
when you're coming into a relationship
you'll probably come with university
debt you're probably coming with
problems from your ex relationship
you're probably coming with
like past issues about emotional needs
you're haunting a lot of everyone for
women
so wait guys guys one more time so
here's the difference
emotional needs you will seek
a man to help you with that whereas i as
a man
if i've got emotional needs i will not
come to you with those emotional needs
and the reason being is that you as a
woman will not understand the struggle
as a man that i go through on a daily
basis so it's very difficult for you to
comprehend and give me advice
on how to deal with my emotional
problems i as a man will probably be
best off
going to seek advice from other males
that i could call friends maybe
counselors in that kind of
realm
in order to get advice on how to go
about my emotional problems
are chemically different on a day-to-day
basis and so
the idea that i could say all right guys
i'm going through these problems you may
see it from a woman's perspective and
you'll go oh well you can do this this
and this
as a man if i take that advice i do
those things i will find the results
are not
suitable or
what i'm looking for because you as a
woman women tend to be more money
colored in today's society men if you do
something you will know by it
you society will tell you that
this can't run and you can't do that
women get away with everything
shout out to people
anytime anytime a guy has a standard
they're ashamed for it but you started
off this conversation by saying don't
you think women have too high standards
they do but i
why 50 of women are single and childless
but that contradicts exactly what how
does that contradict exactly what i said
because you just said if men have a
standard they're kind of ashamed for it
yeah i'll give you an example what
happened with the slut-shaming
slut-shaming fat phobic where's the
equivalent of that for men they don't
exist
if anything if i meet anyone and they
ever say anything to me and i need a
statistic and it's about women and men
i'm phone in power
on
everything
okay literally you're allowed to have
standards as a woman what we're talking
about is too high of a standard where it
only encompasses 20 of men that standard
if you broaden your standard to include
like let's say 50 you'd have a higher
chance of being in a relationship
correct
because you have more people so that's
what we're talking about the reason why
a lot of you are single is because your
standards are too high
men's standards are not the same like
the same the same with the two girls
with the money it doesn't matter for me
what she has the more likely i'll take
the one with less because the one with
more is going to come with complications
she's going to be like i'm the boss of
this stuff i have the most money no no
you can't tell me nothing and dinner
i'm like yo
i don't need the stress i find it really
interesting that you say that because
speaking to all of the women that i know
who are currently single the issues that
we always have are you go on dates you
put yourself into somebody you invest
your time and they all seem to have
commitment issues so that's why because
you're dating 20 percent
yeah
i promise you the bottom eighty percent
of guys they where are they they have no
commitment issues none no way
they're less attractive
the man has commitment issues yeah
in my experience but that's what i'm
saying to you because he's not going to
tell you listen darling this is your
problem this is a b problem this is c
problem this is the problem i'm just
going to cut cut or i'm going to stay
there and not take you seriously
if if he's not committing to you it's
because it's something you're not doing
or you're not fulfilling for him in
terms of what he wants purely the
woman's fault if a man's not committed
if you're not if a girl is asking for
let's say she her asking price is this
much and she says this is this is the
product
this is what i'm selling can someone buy
it and nobody buys something's wrong
with the product
good to know
or the price the price or the price yeah
or the price or the buyer this is just
so you're basically saying there's
there's no issue with so
with the fact that it's so easily
accessible to move on to the next person
with having social media with having
dating apps now that that hasn't caused
an issue in terms of individuals now
committed